so meldung von heute der landrat vom
super hot spot hildburghausen steht
wegen drohungen unter polizeischutz
willkommen in deutschland
passend dazu waren verfassungsschützer
vor der zunehmenden radikalisierung der
querdenker szene
sie wissen schon diese leute die
beschlossen haben dass es so wird gar
nicht gibt damit sie sich weniger
schuldig fühlen wenn sie auf masken und
abstand pfeifen ja um ihre müden leben
mehr dramatik zu verleihen haben viele
von denen sich inzwischen zu
widerstandskämpfern ernannt so ist man
dem eigenen film
gleichzeitig hält und opfer toll hier
exemplarisch vorgemacht von der
inzwischen fast schon prominenten jana
aus kassel
wenn jana aus kassel und ich fühle mich
wie sie durch so viel scheiße da ich
seit monaten hier aktiven widerstand bin
reden heute auf die fußgeher flyer
verteilen oder auch der gestern
versammlung anmelden
ja das sind diese momente wo ich
deutschlands bildungssystem insgesamt
infrage stelle kann man in geschichte
jahre lang fehlen
ist das möglich heutzutage ja jana aus
kassel reitzig wie selbstverständlich
ein in die ahnenreihe großer
freiheitskämpfer der geschichte ich habe
versucht hitler umzubringen aber diese
jana meldet versammlung an
habt ihr eine ahnung wie gefährlich das
ist
mein gott der ich doch nur wie
jana aus kassel
[Musik]
amen übrigens ist das mädchen kein
einzelfall
tausende von erwachsenen querdenkern
halten sich auch für widerstands hellen
immer mit dem wohligen gefühl dass ihnen
nicht wirklich was passieren kann weiß
er gar nicht in einer diktatur leben
gratis mut nennt man das auf den
querdenker demos marschieren weiter
heilpraktiker einträchtig neben sieg
heil praktikern schnittmenge ist ihre
offene verachtung für die
parlamentarische demokratie und deren
gewählte vertreter und natürlich ihre
freude an der umdeutung von geschichte
da wird er mal eben als beispiel das
infektionsschutzgesetz zum
ermächtigungsgesetz der nazis auch bei
der afg übrigens hier genau zuhören
sigmund freud lässt grüßen
sie haben in vollem bewusstsein aus
opportunität oder unfähigkeit für ein
gesetz gestimmt dass die tür zur
demokratie aufstößt schämen sie sich
genau wenn du die tür zur demokratie
einmal aufgestoßen hast brandgefährlich
wirklich was ich nicht wusste querdenken
ist inzwischen ein regelrechtes business
stichwort merchandising fanartikel und
michael ball weg der gründer der
bewegung erhält von seinen fans immer
wieder großzügige schenkung auf sein
privatkonto wieviel verräter nicht denn
es gibt keine anzeigepflicht für
schenkungen unter 20.000 euro total
praktisch wir schalten live rhein bei
dennis knossalla er moderierte neuen
shopping kanal qvc der knossalla stimmt
das dass sich eine handvoll
busunternehmen gerade dumm und dämlich
verdient weil sie die querdenker von
einer demo zu anderen karren peter
oliver hab ich dich richtig verstanden
du möchtest bei quer vc eine busreise
buchen nein großartig da habe ich
zufällig genau das richtige für dich im
angebot oliver und zwar schnall dich an
eine quer tours kaffeefahrt zum
geburtshaus von attila hildmann nur 499
euro dazugibt ich dreh durch unser
komplettes demo paket darin enthalten
sein eigener halle hut eine heizdecke
von attila hildmann persönlich gesegnete
veganen und eine friedensfahne passt
super denn nach so einer fahrt im
rappelvollen bous trifft man
vielleicht seine oma und schenkt ihr den
ewigen frieden und für einen winzigen
aufpreis gibt es sogar eine exklusive
hildmann handy groß botschaft nein
doch wir euch alle wir impfen euch alle
bis zum stalinistischen merkel
entwickelt super ob mit 30 euro mehr
zieht der ss uniform an gar nicht nötig
ich finde ja ihre geschäfte mit dem
reisen und die erwähnten schenkung
passen nicht so richtig zum
aufgeblasenen freiheitskämpfer getue
verstehe
der uli ist keine freiheitskämpfer
schade aber vielleicht ist er ja christ
sehr spezielle christen haben wir auch
im wird im sortiment sogar bessere
christen als die mainstream kirche
[Musik]
gut ich bin halt auch gläubig ich glaube
dass jesus gott zurück und dann
wird es lustig wie jetzt bei euch ist
jesus so eine art schlägertyp der hier
bald richtig aufräumt tja das kann man
alles nachlesen
in der neu übersetzten querdenker bibel
ich empfehle das wendler evangelium vor
allem die stelle wo jesus die cdu aus
dem tempel wirft zusammen mit der
heiligen jana aus kassel
jetzt bestellen nur 30 silberlinge
angemahnt
wie wäre es mit dem original querdenker
kruzifix das hat einen querbalken ein
guter knossalla kunden kennen sie schon
den offiziellen querdenker mund
nasenschutz haben mehr war dann unser
grundrecht fürchte ich fürchte dass
vielleicht die infektion mit dem
infektionsschutzgesetz auf möbel ist das
denkt ist das ein ding damit machen wir
die merkel fertig das funktioniert oben
und hinten im zehnerpack nur 1000 euro
ich muss bekloppt sein das stimmt dennis
knossalla vielen dank so werden und
herren spannende frage wann beginnt bei
uns das impfen möglicherweise noch im
dezember heißt es gibt ja inzwischen
mehrere impfstoffe mit hoher wirksamkeit
also sagen die hersteller
hoffentlich stimmt jetzt die schlechte
nachricht laut einer aktuellen umfrage
wollen sich nur 57 prozent der deutschen
impfen lassen zum vergleich in dänemark
sind es 71 prozent in großbritannien 69
was also machen um die impf moral zu
erhöhen
hier ein paar ungebetene ratschläge
ratschläge in die fresse mit friedemann
weise
wer hätte das gedacht dass große impfen
beginnt vielleicht noch dieses jahr aber
statt uns zu freunden diskutieren wir
über logistik und fachkräftemangel
dabei brauchen wir gar nicht mehr
personal wir müssen es nur besser
ausstatten damit die in der gleichen
zeit mehr menschen impfen können so dr
freddy der macht zehn impfungen pro
minute ob du willst oder nicht sein wir
doch auch mal stolz in ganz deutschland
werden gerade in rekordzeit impfzentren
aus dem boden gestampft dieses
messegelände in trier könnte eines der
ersten rheinland-pfälzischen impfzentren
werden schon seit wochen bereitet sich
die stadt darauf vor 4000 der menschen
zu impfen
oh gott das im zentrum sieht hier aus
wie hitler so traut sich ja gar keiner
mehr rein
da bringt man noch nicht im impfpass mit
sondern den führerschein entschuldigung
vor allem beim personal müssen wir
einfach mehr out of the box denken muss
es denn immer jemand mit medizinische
ausbildung sein reicht es nicht wenn man
sich einfach so mit spritzen auskennt
junkies zum beispiel die könnten auf
spielplätzen ganze familien enten haben
wir nichts zu tun oder profi radsportler
die können auch in der kühlbox durch
deutschland radeln und zur abwechslung
mal legale stoffe injizieren eine
spritztour quasi und warum nutzen wir
nicht auch die vorhandene infrastruktur
lasst uns aus jeder mcdonald's filiale
einer ins station machen
da gibt es dann das sparen menü ein mac
biontech mit einer kleinen impfdosen
lauter saft und um auch die älteren
mitzunehmen präsentiert florian
silbereisen das große weihnachtsfest der
ems musik mit hits wie ich mich jetzt
auch wenn ich stinke verdammt ich lieb
dich oder er hat ein knallrotes oberarm
und ein lied darf natürlich auch nicht
fehlen
bei der weihnachtsbäckerei
bist du leider nicht dabei
weiß beweise gibt dass bill gates dich
schickt eine maßlose mccarthy um die
weihnachts sind bereit
beinahe zehn fahrer ok wo ist der infas
geblieben
eigentlich sollte sehr viel
doch jetzt ist der weg nicht erschreckt
naja egal denn erstmal im 5
die alten bevor sie uns noch eher kalt
sind dann nach pflegepersonal aber
vorher noch jens spahn
bei der weihnachts in bahrain ist für
jeden was dabei
90% wirst du im prozent bei natürliche
distanz durch die beine sind bei der
weihnachtsfeier
[Musik]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
los los du scheiße fährt haye